welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Louisa Lombard an assistant professor
of anthropology she's a cultural
anthropologist who studies African
borderland areas where the state is
largely absent and a range of actors
govern professor Lombards research
locales primarily the remote and little
populated eastern reaches of the Central
African Republic are further marked by
violent histories that continue into the
present
her main fieldwork interlocutors are
among the region's men in arms such as
anti poaching guards and rebels today
we'll talk with professor Lombard about
her new book state of rebellion violence
and intervention in the Central African
Republic
welcome professor Longworth thanks
Marilyn let's start with an overview of
your book tell us about it yeah so
really the objective of this book was
that you know this this country the
Central African Republic which I've been
studying since 2003 really began to
descend into war in late 2012 into 2013
and things got really bad there for a
while and I you know this is a country
that has shaped me as a person and as a
scholar and I was following closely
everything that was going on in the
country and I wanted to tell the story
of this conflict of what had been going
on during the war in a way that would
draw out not just the kind of
blow-by-blow of everything that was
happening on a daily basis but that
would also bring in some of the
historical and social factors that had
gone into creating the situation that we
found in the country and it would also
do a little bit of a kind of structural
analysis of the position of central
Africa in the world and one of the
things I realized in telling that story
was that first of all this case of the
Central African Republic actually draws
out a lot of problems with the usual
ways that we understand conflict in
Africa and so I wanted to you know
critique some of those usual ways of
thinking
about conflict in Africa and also
proposed an alternative way of thinking
about understanding and analyzing what's
going on in these places okay because it
seemed to me that you know there have
been some really big shifts in terms of
how conflict happens in Africa today and
one of those is the increased role of
international organizations the UN big
UN missions NGOs all of these kinds of
of actors and so it's really gotten to
the point now where it no longer makes
sense to try to analyze or think about
conflict on the continent as if it were
the product of these sort of bounded
cultures of rebel groups on the one hand
and then you know government actors on
the other hand and international actors
on you know on another third hand if you
happen to have that many what we really
need to understand is how these
different actors are becoming entangled
with each other and developing
relationships with each other that
structure what they're able to do and
what they're not able to do and so
that's some of what I try to do in the
book some of the early sections of the
book talk about sort of what the state
has been in Central African Republic in
the role of violence in it and the
reasons why the kind of label of failed
state although in some sense evocative
of the kind of dysfunction that you find
is analytically not very helpful in
terms of understanding either what has
been happening or what we should do to
try to fix it and then talk about
specific forms of international
intervention that we've seen through the
years disarmament programs and the like
and talk about also the specific forms
of violence that we saw during the war
and sort of where they come from and
some of what they need okay
so I know you spent a lot of time in the
field in central Africa how did you do
your research so this book really grows
out of my research and engagement in
Central African Republic since 2003 so
that's been a few years at this point
and as a cultural anthropologist my
methods are qualitative so I do a range
of things participant observation
interviews hang out with people
participate in meetings all of that kind
of thing so I've
a lot of time you know hanging out with
members of rebel groups and interviewing
them going to United Nations meetings
all of these different kinds of things
and having this perspective of having
done research in the country for you
know a few years at this point has made
it possible for me to track both some of
what has changed during that time and
then also what remains the same and I'm
able to kind of look for patterns and
see patterns and see what is persisting
and what is changing and and what that
really means I'm wondering as a woman if
you were ever you know fearful for
yourself especially being in the field
with rebels did you ever have any kind
of situations that arise where you
didn't feel safe that's a good question
I would say no I could have put myself
into situations that would have been
very scary but I tend to be pretty
careful and I you know do a lot of
groundwork before I go anywhere talking
to different people about what the
situation is like and making sure that
if I go as a researcher who wants to ask
people questions that this will be
welcomed that this will not be taken as
an affront and I always work through
chains of command and hierarchies to
make sure that people know who I am what
I'm doing you know we have luckily here
at Yale an informed consent process or
an ethics overview and I make sure to
follow all of those rules I've been able
to stay pretty safe okay great now you
you spoke of things having changed let's
let's talk about 20 years ago to today
what changes have you seen and why and
also what things have stayed the same so
one of the big changes is that the
region has become much more militarized
and this was starting already more than
20 years ago some of the wars in the in
the region such as in Sudan South Sudan
chad conflict in most places has been
going on for a very long time but it's
really intensified and it's difficult to
summarize the reasons for why that's
happened but the situation that we find
today is that Central African Republic
unfortunately we don't have a map here
but if you can pick
sure it all of its neighbors it's this
landlocked country and all of its
neighbors either have recently been at
war or have high levels of conflict you
know we're talking about Chad Sudan
South Sudan Democratic Republic of the
Congo Republic of Congo I used to say
that Cameroon was the one exception but
now Cameron has seen a lot of conflict
as well with Boko Haram and and related
developments and then Central African
Republic has its own conflict dynamics
so there's been this kind of ramping up
of the militarization of the region and
in concert with that there has been a
ramping up of kind of international
interventions to try to manage and deal
with these conflicts primarily done by
the African Union the the United Nations
but also taking the form of lots of aid
organizations are they helping at all
I think they're doing a lot to help in a
kind of band a band aid type of a way I
don't think that they are really
tackling some of the structural problems
that exist for this country or this
region what are the structural problems
so I think the main structural problem
is that the Central African Republic is
this incredibly improbable state it's
this vast vast area with very few people
and that has always been incredibly poor
during the colonial period as today and
yet we expect it to kind of look like a
state in this pretty typical sort of vey
Berrien model it just can't work it
won't work so we kind of we infuse a
number of international troops in the
form of peacekeeping missions and that
sort of keeps a lid on things for a
while but once they leave the the
fundamental problem is still there that
this is this poor and very weak state
that realistically is going to remain
that way for a very long time unless we
really start thinking differently about
what we might do in this so what are
some of the things that have stayed the
same some of the things that have stayed
the same that's a good question I mean
one unfortunately as I said is this sort
of structural problem of what the
Central African proud Republic is in the
world that it is this very
kind of weak state are a state that has
very little administrative capacity that
is very poor that is very large that has
very little infrastructure and if we
went back 50 years in time again the
region wasn't as militarized and it
wasn't as much of a problem it was kind
of a sleepy backwater um you know people
people liked it for that reason but as
the region has become much more
militarized it's become more and more of
a problem what are the reasons for
becoming more and more militarized I
mean what is going on there that causes
such strife versus having it be peaceful
well I think one factor I mean now I'll
just talk about Central African Republic
and I'm gonna leave out other countries
in the region but one factor was that
during the 1980s the country was in an
economic plummet and one of the
proposals by different international
actors the World Bank those kinds of
people was to say well what you really
need to do is become more efficient as a
government trim the civil service stop
hiring people moved to multiparty
democracy and elections all of these
good things and one consequence of that
was that it meant that the number of
people who were able to materially
benefit from the state was being
constrained and couldn't be expanded and
people started to feel left out and one
way that they had to protest and to say
no we need to be taken seriously is by
taking up arms and so it started with
army mutinies in the 1990s with members
of the with soldiers saying we're not
getting paid this is crazy
and then turned into a number of
rebellions I'm also all taking this this
form of saying no we need to be taken
seriously and being taken seriously
means I you know giving us some kind of
material dignity in addition to
everything else so that's that's one set
of factors
something that really interested me in
your book is the role the occults plays
so if you could talk a little bit about
that and how it's affected you know
Central Africa yeah so this is a big
thing inside
Africa and we could use a variety of
different words to talk about it the
occult witchcraft sorcery is sort of a
local term the problem with all of this
terminology is at the moment that we
hear the word witchcraft we start
thinking pointy hats brooms all of these
different kinds of things and that
doesn't really describe the whole sort
of world of witchcraft in central Africa
I think at the most fundamental level
we're talking about the occult or
witchcraft in central Africa we're
really talking about is that there's a
sort of widespread understanding that
the world consists of there's kind of
two worlds one is visible and sensible
and the other is invisible but people
can still be active in that kind of
invisible world and through that
invisible world can have an effect on
you and your and your life and the
understanding for a lot of people in
central Africa is that basically every
person has the capacity to become really
powerful in terms of witchcraft and use
that for their own betterment for their
own advancement and also to keep other
people back but most people don't do
anything with it most people just let it
lie they don't want to get involved in
that kind of thing but some people work
to kind of develop that capacity and
when they do that can have very you know
effects that people see as very
antisocial again such as you know making
it so that one person gets ahead but
usually in getting ahead somebody else
they feel like somebody else is getting
behind and so when people make recourse
to witchcraft saying it was because of
rich crafts that that guy is doing so
much better
in part it's an attempt it's a way of
assigning responsibility and
accountability for what people perceive
to be social ills and social wrongs okay
do do you think people use it I will say
inappropriately to cast aspersions on
another person purposely that definitely
happens luckily there are a range of
different criteria that have to be that
have to obtain for something - for
people to believe that accusation okay
and so people will be accused of
witchcraft and it will be found that
that accusation was baseless and
and you know the person who accused will
be the one who will lose face in that
situation doesn't always work that way
you know there are people who are
accused and if you went back and looked
at the evidence when you're in a sort of
cooler headed frame of mind you might
think differently from when you're in
the thick of the accusation but there is
some you know there are some parameters
for this that okay that keep it from
getting totally out of hand okay help me
understand when you say witchcraft
how does someone develop their
witchcraft in terms of getting stronger
I mean do they do ceremonies what
actually happens so often times they
would involve apprentice thing to
somebody who is a known sorcerer and
learning from that person and a lot of
how what goes on there is secret it's
not something that those of us who want
to claim that we are not witches and
don't know about witchcraft
not something that we would want to know
okay but it does involve various plants
that can have both medicinal and then
also kind of occult function in a range
of things okay interesting so what do
you think central Africa needs in terms
of moving the country forward well
unfortunately I think that the list of
things it needs are is long but let me
just mention two things today okay one
is that you know right now in the
country we have all of these people lots
of smart people both central Africans
and people from elsewhere trying to work
on the country's problems and trying to
make things better the problem is that
all of them have a very short-term kind
of lens for their engagement with the
country so if you're working for the UN
any project that you can push through is
going to have a funding cycle of maybe
two years maybe three years something
along those lines um so it's only ever
going to be this very short-term kind of
thing if you're a Central African
politician for a variety of reasons you
also tend to be thinking in a very
short-term kind of a way and the problem
is that the problems in central Africa
are long-term problems and they require
a real long term vision leadership
somebody who is going to sort of take
the reins and say we're gonna push this
or word and think in that long-term kind
of a way and be able to implement things
in a long-term kind of a way so there
needs to be some kind of fundamental
rethinking of how we give assistance to
this country and the way that we do it
so that's one set of problems that I
think we really need to grapple with and
figure out and then I also think that
you know there's a lot of emphasis on
sort of rebuilding the state in central
Africa well as I mentioned earlier the
state has never really had much of a
presence in in Central African Republic
it's always been very poor and hasn't
been great at providing services to
citizens so what if we sort of stop
focusing on the state as service
provider and instead start thinking
about what the state might be able to do
in terms of assuring that people have
some very basic level of material
dignity give people some money and then
see what they do with that right
basically I think that we need to work
more in the direction of a politics of
distribution and of giving the central
Africans that kind of rightful share you
know some not a lot of money but some
small amount that kind of is a way of
creating some accountability between
their leaders and and the citizens in
the country and that also goes a long
way toward just providing the kind of
grist for the small-scale kind of inter
economic transactions on a village level
on a town level that really get things
going okay so what would you like a
reader to take away from your book well
you know in the conclusion of the book I
quote a peanuts comic strip that was
actually first quoted by a great
anthropologist Clifford Geertz
and he quoted in the context of research
that he was doing in the 1960s and what
were then called the new States you know
sort of the post-colonial world and in
this comic strip Lucy says to Charlie
Brown she says you know what the problem
is with you Charlie Brown the problem
with you is that you are you and Charlie
Brown sort of looks at her I was like
well what am I supposed to do about that
Lizzie says I don't provide solutions I
just get to the you know
diagnose the root causes of the problem
and that comic-strip really resonated
with me because I think you know as an
academic as a researcher it's easy to
just kind of critique and point out the
problems but there are a lot of people
out there people who are working in
Central Africa now who are faced with
these really big problems and yet have
to try to figure out some way to move
forward some way to you know make make
decisions about about how we can try to
do something for this country and so you
know I really hope that people in
reading my book you know one of the
things I tried to do is sort of show you
know sort of readjust realign some of
the the frameworks that we bring to bear
to try to understand a place like that
like this and in doing so to provoke for
both people to think about things
differently provoke people to perhaps
come up with some different ideas for
what we might be able to do for this
country because ultimately you know my
hope is that this book will be you know
some kind of a testament to just the the
the the the challenges and privations
privations that so many central Africans
we've been so generous with their time
and and other things with me through the
years have to have to deal with and
it'll help us perhaps you know that
perhaps out of the critique we will also
find ways to perhaps a shore at least a
slightly more dignified future for
central Africans in the years to come
ok this has been very interesting thanks
so much for being here and thank you
Marilyn oh you're welcome
for more information about Professor
Lombard and her research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through the funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you
[Music]
you